Steve, il faut du courage pour abandonner comme vous l'
avez fait l'enseignement supérieur se fait au
détriment de l'expérience laver sur quoi
travaillez-vous, c'est un terminal informatique qui se
connecte au téléviseur à l'écran euh Steve Wow
dessert à la pointe de la technologie personne ne fait
quelque chose comme  c'est
ok bienvenue l'ordinateur utile c'est
tout le démarrage je pense que nous devrions
commencer avec environ 90 000, pourriez-vous
répéter que si vous
m'ennuyez croyez-moi ndep Deacon tapal incorporé
est devenu public mademoiselle Morton étrange c'est
notre sport nous devons faire les petites
choses  police de caractères inoubliable ce n'est pas un
problème urgent sortez il essaie de
déclencher une guerre avec IBM Steve fait
l'impossible depuis qu'il était dans un
garage j'essaie de construire une pomme et
ils me la prennent si vous
continuez  en empruntant cette voie je ne
te protégerai pas c'est une arnaque flagrante je vais
te poursuivre en justice pour chaque set tu es
ton pire ennemi
le conseil d'administration est unanime Steve ne sera
plus impliqué dans cette entreprise
dix ans après  Le départ de Steve Jobs, l'
avenir de l'ordinateur Apple est en danger
dans la vie, vous ne pouvez faire que tant de
choses qui
rendront Apple cool à nouveau,
voici les fous Les Misfits les
rebelles
parce que les gens qui sont assez fous
pour penser qu'ils peuvent changer le monde  d'
autres qui, si nous voulons faire cette chose, nous
devons trouver un nom Apple qui
soit tellement meilleur que les ordinateurs à faisceau de phaser